I'm actually at the bar right now too uh
my question for you is why are our
attractions the lyrics by anyone knows
the girlfriend of eight years I just
legit just seen a lot of weird large
fractions tonight
how can we solve that and have Humanity
not quality so anti-social not saying
that I'm just before I could start on
the planet because I'm not but just out
of curiosity I want to know what United
States about bar interactions and people
looking at each other at a bar so this
guy
also the first show that she's artwork
has I've seen in my life thank you very
much best artwork he's ever seen on his
life he's always said about my show in
Minneapolis that's nice okay we like
them oh wow he said best artist ever
seen his life that's what he said wow
okay I really like that guy like a smash
to [__] Smithereens for real
so I came in a bar in a bar why is it
it's so weird when you have an
interaction I have a girlfriend at eight
years so what's up what's up there's a
lot of looks on the bars or something
like that anyway say Minneapolis best
artwork I've ever seen in my entire life
so love you guys both bye
just threw up and then slipped on it and
bonked his head and died oh that made me
a little nauseous just hearing it
well it's the best part you've ever seen
in your life uh yeah dude get out of the
bar you know or uh just [__] stop you
know toss it when you're out of the bar
you know what was the question why are
interactions so weird at bars
oh you don't even know because you've
never been drunk he's smashed this guy's
[__] exhilarating you've never I know
but he's blitzed
he's three sheets to the wind
yeah but that's not anything to do with
what I'm saying he's faded dude
hello hello hello
[Music]